this is just so weird ridiculous
radical rancid and regressive republican
congresswoman lauren bober
falsely claimed the other day that the
state of texas
hasn't recorded even one coveted death
in more than two months what the hell is
she talking about
speaking to right-wing commentator gina
louden
on dr gina prime time
bober ridiculed the house mandate for
mask wearing
said she enjoys telling speaker nancy
pelosi to
kiss her mask clever right maybe english
comprehension is suffering on my end
maybe this is not actually what lauren
beaubert is saying but i've watched this
three times now
it really sounds like lauren beaubert is
saying
nobody in texas has died of covid since
march 2nd when they pulled
the mask mandate also by the way pay
attention to her
defiant and principled opposition to
everything that public health experts
are proposing
but listen carefully here uh i think
she's saying
nobody in texas died of covet since
march 2nd take a look
you know i'm really enjoying uh telling
speaker pelosi to kiss my
mask though uh yesterday thomas massey
madison cawthorne brian mast
beth van dyne and several other
colleagues join me in refusing to wear
a mask on the house floor thomas massey
and i both got
warnings and uh both of our letters
ended up in the same exact place
ironically
the trash leftists won't even listen to
the bureaucratic the bureaucrats at the
cdc
and it just goes to show that this
party's follow the science slogan
is a total joke just like this entire
administration just like the entire
democrat party
they want to tell you to listen to
science and listen to data and facts but
they haven't done that for more than a
year
uh two weeks to slow the spread turned
into communism
really really quickly now let's show me
your papers
uh but don't forget gina texas removed
their mask mandate
two months ago and sleepy joe called it
neanderthal thinking no sir republicans
are
just following the science and since
removing the mass mandate
two months ago texas has not reported a
single
coveted death not one she said it
she is saying that in texas there has
not been
a single covet death since they pulled
their mask mandate
now unfortunately the truth is 3 600
texans have died of covid
since march 2nd march 2nd is the day
restrictions were lifted
in the graph we're showing you march 2nd
is where the red arrow is pointing
and as you can see numbers far greater
than zero
every single day since that day so what
could she even have meant
by by this does uh lauren bobert know
that this is a lie
but she's counting on viewers of this
bizarre show
not knowing that it's a lie not knowing
it obviously doesn't pass the sniff test
and not fact checking it
does lauren beaubert herself somehow
actually think
nobody died of covet in texas since
march 2nd
the test in 2022 is going to be
does lauren beaubert get re-elected or
does she get removed from congress
this is a really anti-american person
remember that lauren beaubert
back in december tweeted save the date
january 6 2021
we know how january 6th turned out we
know that lauren bobert
gave guided tours of the capitol
right before the january 6th
insurrection even though
the policy at the time was no guided
tours of the capital
we know that lauren bober tried to use
the recent boulder colorado mass
shooting
to say that we need more guns in more
places which is just the idea she came
in with she'll use anything
to justify more guns in more places um
and this is a a truly you know the
the right loves to claim uh for
themselves
the privilege or right or
ownership of what is patriotism and what
does it mean to be for
the united states of america but some of
these people
are truly the most anti-american people
that you will meet in terms of
principles
in terms of their perspective on what it
actually means
to abide by the constitution and to
provide people due process
and access to all of the things which
they are entitled to through the
constitution and the bill of rights
this is a disgusting disgusting person
and
if she gets reelected in 2022 if
marjorie taylor green gets reelected in
2022
if madison cawthorne gets reelected in
2022
it will really ingrain that this is the
party of trump
and this is the party that has abandoned
what were already pretty bad principles
i mean let's be let's be pretty frank
it's not like the republican party was a
great thing under reagan
under mccain romney etc
uh but it was better than what they have
right now and they have a choice to make
now and they will get to make it in
what is it 18 months we're 18 months
from the midterm elections
do they say yeah this is what we want
more of lauren bobert
marjorie taylor green cawthorne the
whole lot of them
or will they say there has to be some
limit to this i don't know the answer to
that
but we will have more on this and other
stories from today's show
on our instagram find us at david pakman
show
and while you're there follow me on
instagram david.pakman i've been getting
some really wacky hate mail lately
and i posted one of them to my instagram
david.pacman
let me know what you think one of our
sponsors today is
covid rescue fund covid rescue fund
is helping small business owners who
have lost
their businesses during covid there are
over 100
000 small businesses that have had to
close their doors
since the pandemic began there are many
organizations out there
helping businesses who are still open to
stay afloat
but covet rescue fund is one of the few
organizations working to help businesses
reopen who have had to close covet
rescue fund
crowdsources funds to provide grants up
to one hundred thousand dollars
for these owners to create new
businesses
i would implore anyone in my audience to
help covet rescue fund in their mission
by donating at covidrescufund.org
all money that you give is going to the
mission
not to compensating people who work for
the organization
the founders of covid rescue fund are
big fans of the david pakman show
let's help them bring back as many small
businesses as we can
the link is right underneath this video